I know I said I wouldn't make another
Velma video but as the show has been
airing I couldn't help but think how
much crazier the show got and what the
10 worst scenes of the show are because
I'm sure you guys are at least curious
about how bad Velma really gets without
further Ado let's go into number 10.
Velma and Daphne fighting in a
tournament if this scene surprises you
in any way then you're in for a wild
ride because this is tame in comparison
to the other worst scenes it's also kind
of hard to quantify worse scenes because
most of them are really fast in the show
so I'll be stretching the definition of
a scene a bit when you think of Velma do
you think of someone who's good at
wrestling or fighting no and why is that
is it because their character is
supposed to be a smart person who uses
her witch to solve Mysteries like it's
okay if she understands self-defense but
making it to where she's making it to
the finals of this tournament is
ridiculous it's mostly used as a plot
device to have Velma and Daphne go head
to head which is obviously a contrivance
but this show is so down in the gutter
that that doesn't really bother me
anymore there are so many other
horrendous scenes in the show that are
worse than this just as a concept this
entire scene from a character's
standpoint does not fit Velma it works
for Daphne because they change their
character to be more rough and competent
at hand-to-hand combat although she does
flat out kill someone during the
tournament which is just yeah that
happens but Velma doesn't ever feel like
she belongs here and it all feels very
forced number nine Fred hitting on
female brains now out of context this
Probably sounds very weird so to fill
you in really quick the Killer is
obsessed with the notion of stealing
people's brains and putting them into
other people's bodies which they can
then take over and live in their skin if
this is sounding familiar to you at all
then you would be correct because this
is the exact same premise as another
popular horror movie I would say the
name but it would be a major spoiler for
that movie so if you know then you know
going back to the scene on hand Fred is
Romancing three popular girls who had
their brains stolen earlier in the show
who he finds in this cave now initially
I feel like I would hate the scene a lot
more than I do and I don't know if the
show is desensitizing me to all the
crazy [__] that has happened but this
scene isn't flat out terrible the only
reason for me is that at the very least
the writers give Fred some semblance of
character development even though his
starting point in the show is hellish he
learns to love the personality of woman
instead of being attracted to their
physical attributes but this development
is portrayed through him falling in love
with literal brains so it's a definition
of strange along with him having a love
triangle between the brains which is
interesting to say the least this show
is so detached from reality that it's
crazy number eight Velma pretending to
be a man this is exactly what you'd
imagine Mindy Kaling having some
annoying heavy-handed commentary about
how easy it is to be a man everyone
instantaneously loves Velma now that she
has a mustache and it's so Force person
annoying that I can't find this funny by
any degree she even has a moment where
she nut Taps a sheriff and since she's a
man he just laughs it off the part of
this whole sequence that really feels
the worst is her going on stage and
essentially giving a speech anything she
says immediately receives cheers and
Applause because as you guessed it she's
a man now great comedy this is the only
stretch of the show where this doesn't
feel like Scooby-Doo at all and feels
like an excuse for Mindy kanling to do a
stand-up routine although Velma as a
whole doesn't feel like anything
resembling Scooby-Doo but still this
scene feels so detached I know this
entire show is weird and bizarre but
most jokes like this utterly compromise
the writing and turn everyone into brain
dead idiots to make the joke seem
funnier how can I form any attachment to
these characters when they ping-pong
between competent Geniuses and morons
it's also really creepy how Daphne is
attracted to this version of Velma and
Velma kind of taking advantage of that
it gave off very weird Vibes and this
whole scene is just annoying the only
moment that semi lands is velma's
mustache being real when Fred rips it
off but that's really it if you love
superficial commentary about men having
it easy in society then this scene is
for you number seven opening naked
locker room scene this was such a
jarring way to start the show when first
watching it I was in disbelief about how
immature and juvenile and flat out
disgusting the show is coming off let's
overly sexualize these high schoolers in
a meta joke about how there's more sex
and nudity in the opening episode of the
shows they put an immediate bad taste in
my mouth that I could never get over
they even have a moment where
cockroaches are having sex I guess the
writers thought it would be funny but it
again cements the scene as being
immature despite the supposedly being a
more adult rendition of Scooby-Doo
there's really no reason the scene has
to take place in a locker room and you
could literally interchange it with any
other location also the dialogue in the
scene is almost entirely breaking the
fourth wall between the writers
acknowledging the nudity and in entire
exchange between Velma calling out
Daphne from being white to Asian and for
some reason Vilma comes in and decks the
hell out of Daphne with a hockey stick
the writers in the scene do not set a
good first impression and probably
scared off a lot of viewers from how bad
it was number six velma's locker room
nude scene now you'd think the first
locker room scene would be a weird one
and done scene that was a fever dream
but nope the writers do it again and
this time we get to see Velma without
her clothes Jesus Christ I need to purge
my eyes from their sockets I can't
believe they actually showed us Velma
like this let alone any of the
characters naked in the first place it
feels like their integrity has been
destroyed and violated throughout this
entire show and to me this moment
crosses the line was it necessary for
her to take off her clothes here no not
at all it's only done because of a meta
jug prior in which these girls are
talking about dramatic entrances and TV
shows that and I guess they're trying to
do double standards since the quote
unquote hot girl known as Dash Daphne
was naked earlier on in the show but I
don't want them to overly sexualize any
of these characters these writers need
professional help after this number five
Sophie's pregnant nude photo shoots out
of all the scenes I think this one
surprised me the most from how purely
and utterly bizarre and random it is out
of nowhere the scene transitions to a
bit about Sophie taking nude photos this
is our first impression of this new
character and this is what you decided
to do with her and the fact that this is
completely normal in the eyes of our
characters is odd it kind of sets the
tone of how wacky and weird the show is
with blunt head force trauma by showing
us this I would put the scene higher on
the list but Sophie isn't a character
that's pre-existing so her being ruined
In This Moment doesn't make me upset
because I had no prior attachment to her
it would be nice if we had a somewhat
normal scene to ease her in instead of
this but hey now all I can think about
is this a weird pregnant only fans Lady
when I see her in later scenes this is
also a pretty a quick scene in
comparison to the others on this list so
it's hard to determine if it should be
lower because of that regardless though
it still put me in shock number four
Fred getting shot and being nude the
first episode has some insane scenes
that are essentially unmatched
throughout the entire show or again the
show just wore me down so much to the
point that the crazy scenes throughout
Velma had less of an impact on my psyche
however making it seem like Fred was
about to kill Velma and then the cops
showing up and shooting his legs was
shocking to say the least it's just
obviously so overboard and is one of
those times in which the show crosses
the line for absurdity because that's
what the show is at its core since it's
so absurd it's always coming across as
cocaine field writing that puts you in a
constant state of shock it's constantly
compromising characters in every
particle tied to the biological makeup
of this show is drenched in stupidity I
wouldn't be surprised if the bear from
cocaine bear got some crayons and went
to town for this scraps this scene also
hurts even more because this is one of
the first times where Fred does
something so unhinged that any human
would question what they're doing along
with the writers stripping away the
character's dignity by having his robes
fall off in front of reporters like I
don't know what the writer's obsession
is with stripping these characters butt
naked because it's disgusting they're
also supposed to be teenagers here so
having a bunch of reporters take nude
photos of a child is flat out wrong at
the very least we didn't see norvel
naked in the show or am I lying to you
now and will he show up later in the
list number three Velma and her father
going to a strip club I wish I could be
making this up apparently in the show
Sophie's Diner turns into a strip club
for I don't know they don't explain why
my only assumption for this scene is
that the writers thought this would be
funny wouldn't it be hilarious if a
father takes her daughter to a strip
club in reality it's very awkward and
immature like the vast majority of the
humor in the show it's even crazier
because Velma and her father are trying
to bond in the scene and I can't take
anything seriously because there are
strippers in the background it turns a
scene that I could have resonated with
emotionally but that was ripped away due
to its setting now if it was just them
talking in a strip club and that was it
then the scene would probably be like
number 10 but that isn't the case and
Velma starts pole dancing [__] me man
why are they doing this to me why am I
making this video I should have just
done a cocaine bear review instead all I
can see now when I think of Velma is her
pole dancing and her dumb nude locker
room scene then the writers have the
audacity to make Velma say this I'm
doing what every girl is doing up here
I'm just trying to get my dad's
attention I think that is the most
disgusting thing I've ever heard in a
long time and the fact that it's coming
from Velma of all characters in
television history is surreal also Fred
is randomly in the strip club too by the
way but at this point that's just normal
I guess the show is actually Breaking Me
down and setting my expectations so low
for what kind of atrocities come next
number two Fred's trial another classic
scene from the first two episodes now
this entire trial is the epitome of
character assassination the writers
demolished Fred so badly to the point
that he's irredeemable in my eyes there
hasn't been this level of character
destruction since Tyrion Lannister in
Game of Thrones Freud is now a whiny
brat is spoiled hateful psychotic and
competent a baby and really any negative
characteristic you can think of is
embodied by Fred here we have iconic
moments like Velma taking the stand and
testifying under oath that Fred has a
small [__] we have Fred not knowing how
to cut a stake and him jumping onto the
table and threatening to kill people
this entire scene is some sick joke and
the Absurd nature of the show is like a
tank rolling over the Scooby-Doo
franchise Fred and the scene was done
the most Injustice and it's honestly
kind of sad how much the writers hate
Fred they just use them as a Perpetual
punching bag of constant jokes of white
rich men being bad he doesn't feel like
an actual character and instead a vessel
for the show to make fun of and drag
through the mud why they chose to do
this with a beloved character is beyond
me and the fact that Warner Bros was
okay with this is pretty insane that's
why I'm still choosing to believe that
the higher-ups didn't read the scripts
like imagine if this was done with
Batman or something there would be no
way that would fly number one the gang
catching the killer oh no no no here we
go guys now this was the main reason why
I decided to make this video because I
saw this without actually watching the
show and it made me want to dive into
the Velma Rabbit Hole so let's walk
through this scene shall we Fred's mom
is the killer spoilers although you
don't care and she has a gun trained on
the kids then Norville comes down with a
sword and as she shoots him he deflects
the bullet towards a rock out cropping
that breaks and crushes her thus killing
the killer they're sprayed by Blood and
then Velma twerks on her corpse now if
it was just a killer getting crushed
then I'd put it lower but the fact that
velma's basically doing a fortnight
dance on her corpse is the most jarring
moment in the entirety of the show and
probably anything I've ever watched like
I'd rather watch cats again than watch
through anything in this show this
moment shattered me when I was already
broken to me that's the worst scene and
I can honestly make an argument for the
last few scenes being worse but I was in
a State of shock for a whole minute
after watching this good job writers I'm
happy devolved Velma into a fortnight
dancing twerking Menace they literally
just killed a person and you have her do
that Jesus Christ at this point in the
show they could literally do anything
and it would appear normal if this video
does well I really want to quiz my
friends and make them figure out which
scenes are real in the show and which
ones I make up because I could go crazy
with the fake make prompts and I could
match it with equally crazy moments that
are in the show so that game show could
be fun and thank you for watching I hope
you had a good time getting the spark
notes of the worst scenes from Velma and
feasting on my misery like a vampire